to say in your blog post that you go
fifteen thousand dollars a month is all
i need i'm happy that was like ten years
ago i think but uh that's but you used
to say fifteen thousand
single and no kids is easy right now if
i had a guess on my burn rate 120 to 180
a month what that's insane so what is
how does that break down so what what's
the like what's the bulk of it whether
so house probably is the biggest one
no i have no mortgage okay so you're
spending 120 180k without spending
anything on your home
[Music]
so
neil i i was telling you a little bit
about what you're getting into we record
everything by the way so like we just
hop into it but
sean kind of knows who you are i've been
a fan of yours for like 10 years can i
tell sean and the audience who i think
you are and you could tell me if i'm
wrong and like what i'm missing
sure go for it all right so you're neil
patel so i know you because you used to
have this blog called quick sprout i
read it
maybe 10 years ago it's probably a 15
year old blog if i remember correctly at
first it was mostly about like seo but
eventually it kind of like warped into
being about seo about content but just
about business in general
and you would do like crazy stuff like
you would build a business that made a
hundred thousand dollars a month in
revenue by like you just picked like a
random niche and i think it ended up
being supplements and you like blogged
every month about how that was going and
you used to blog about all types of
crazy stuff but then eventually you also
started a company called crazy egg which
i heard was doing many millions of
dollars a year in revenue and it was a
bootstrap and you own the whole thing
then you and heaton started kissmetrics
and raised a bunch of money it didn't
end up working out wonderfully but it
was like uh it could have been actually
quite huge heaton wrote a great blog
post about like where uh you know where
a couple errors were made but now you've
got like a seven or eight hundred person
agency that is also a bootstrap like the
rest of your stuff and you've just kind
of been balling out like for like 15
years in the world of business just
killing it with agencies is that right
did i get everything mostly right
mostly closed so crazy came first
uh heathen's a co-founder on that he has
it all or uh you know he owns
uh
crazy egg um as well so it's not just me
anymore and then
there's another guy named john butler
who was also part of crazy egg at the
beginning
and then
quick sprout came later i started
blogging on about business and stuff
like that
uh kissmetrics then came kissmetrics
didn't work out quick sprout started to
have a big audience related to marketing
we tried to create seo software on there
i did that with my co-founder heathen at
the time he's like all right how about
we create a company out of this i'll do
the software
that didn't work out i didn't want to be
part of it anymore he took it over
and
he ended up making it a
[Music]
business site directory
you know informational site whatever you
want to call it has affiliate offers
which you already know about and then
the last one was the ad agency which is
correct and then there's been a lot of
stuff in between here and there a lot
didn't work out but generally speaking i
tend to do one thing at once focus and
currently i spend all my time on my ad
agency and that you're you're at six
seven hundred how big is that at the
moment and it's only like five or six
years old right
yeah so we're on our fifth year and then
this year will be end of year five uh
we're at roughly 700 people i think
maybe a little bit more maybe by the
year 900-ish
if i had a guest
who are these people
these are like 700 anonymous indians in
india what's going on who are these
people uh we do have some people in
india
uh
but what's funny how many people do you
employ in new york that's what i want to
know that's my agency testimony
you're in brazil too though right
yeah we're in brazil majority of our
people are in the united states if i
look at a region wise the united states
has the biggest head count we also have
offices in australia canada uh uk brazil
india
i think we're opening up germany soon
we're looking at italy we're looking at
france and a few other regions as well
but our model is is like our ad agency
in india markets companies in india it's
not really used to outsource
american work into india
and what work are people doing like
what's the service that you're providing
all digital so like seo pay-per-click
email marketing conversion rate
optimization organic social paid social
the list goes on and on and do all the
customers come from neilpatel.com
it used to be that way then we started
getting a lot through word of mouth i
would have never really guessed that
word of mouth drives business
how how many can you say how many
uh so most people i would say like our
audience they'd be like oh yeah it's
cool to have like a personal brand but
me and sam have figured out oh wow this
[__] really does open up more doors than
you would have expected
uh you've been doing this for a long
time so neil patel which is kind of like
a personal blog where you're talking
about like you know hacks and
experiments and strategies that you've
you know figured out
how many can you say how many millions
that brought in in client bookings what
for the agency like what
uh how big did just the referrals from
neil patel get you before other stuff
kicked in like word of mouth and being
recognized in the industry and other
things like that i think the neil patel
brand got us to around like 30 40
million in revenue and then word of
mouth started kicking in and then other
things started kicking in and employees
started bringing in their own deals
because they worked in the space for so
long and then we saw more and more
growth got awards that brought us deals
um being a minority owned business that
helps believe it or not there's if
you're indian and you live in the united
states you're considered a minority and
uh
i was about to say are we a minority i
think you guys feel like i never get
minority
you're the majority of ceos out there so
i mean
it's funny because we go through rfps
and some of them ask if you're
what is it like mbe certification or
something like that i forgot what it's
called or minority business enterprise
and i was like well i'm not a minority
there's like one plus billion of me in
this world right and they're like oh
you're a minority i'm like what are you
talking about there's like a billion
plus indians in this world how are we a
minority and they're like oh in america
you're a minority and in some of these
rfps they're looking it says in there
we're looking for um lgbtq
i don't know what the yeah
all four of the letters are um
you have the tattoo on your arm
yeah the queue's there
and then a woman-owned businesses
veteran-owned businesses and the other
one was minority
and i was just like wait there's
actually a quota that these big fortune
500 companies have to hit and they're
like yeah and i was like well i'm a
minority they're like well you need the
certification and i was like i gotta
have a certification to tell you that
i'm a minority and at first i didn't
realize i was a minority they were
telling me oh you're a minority we
reached out to you we're hoping that you
would be a good fit and i'm like i'm a
minority and they're like yeah you're a
minority in the united states you'd help
us meet our quota do you have the
certification i'm like what are you
talking about and then we went through
the process and got the certification
you got to get your papers bro you got
to get your papers right
i would have been offended and then as
soon as i realized wait this is to my
advantage oh hold on um i also got solar
panels on my house does that help you
know like i'm a dog wearing glasses uh
yeah exactly i have a vision impairment
uh called farsightedness
you know so what else works in my favor
here you know like was the certificate
just turned the webcam on and it looked
at you and it was like yep
that was it that's not enough and what's
funny is our ceo or vp operations one of
the titles i forgot what tracy's title
is she asked me for this like six months
before we did it she's like hey need
your birth certificate i'm like yeah why
do you need my birth certificate she's
like oh we need him for this
certification like whatever
and the moment someone ended up telling
me how uh magic johnson generates a lot
of his revenue because he's a minority
and gets a lot of contracts partners
with other businesses white labels it
and
uses his name becomes a quote-unquote
owner of that business and then
outsources oh wait tell me about that
give me an example what's what's an
example of the magic johnson formula
sure so i don't know if this is true
this is just what someone in the
minority space ended up telling me so
that's the caveat i don't know if this
is true or real and they're saying let's
say if someone has a food company and
they have the contracts with all the
hospitals that are run by the government
like the va
they're looking for minorities to
provide it but there's already a lot of
big corporations that provide the food
so magic johnson may go create a
business that's in that space partner
with the big supplier who already
provides a food to these hospitals he'll
go get the contracts and then work with
them to actually put those yeah wait you
never heard you never heard of this my
my in-laws my in-laws own a moving
company and they're minorities they're
uh black they're haitian immigrants and
they win deals partially because of that
reason because like morgan stanley or
something like that if they want to move
they want to they have some type of
policy in their company it says we we
want to get rfps for or we want to get
bids from these types of companies
i had no idea how i didn't obviously i
knew this exists i just didn't realize
how significant it was i definitely
didn't know the magic johnson formula
which
is frankly genius on his part if that's
if that's actually what he does right we
don't know that part but it's true but
think of it this way right it's a quota
so if i go and i get an rfp let's say
from boeing which funny enough we lost
the rfp because we're over spice for
what they wanted um and racism let's say
the price is very similar to the
competition i have rewards showing that
we were the agency of the year so like
all right these guys are good at what
they do we have the case studies
and if we're similar pricing like oh
this is minority helps us hit our quota
let's give the business here right
yeah yeah of course you have some merit
uh to go with it for the first 30
million dollars of business you got that
and you must have gotten that by year
two or so if you're growing this fast um
what was the main year three sorry
three
what was the main service like when i
think of like
because i went to your website and i
actually submitted a lead to figure it
out there was the maximum you ask what
your website is
and what your budget is and it's like
zero to ten thousand ten thousand twenty
thousand and then just fifty 000 plus so
were you serving like mostly small
businesses and what like what were you
were you doing as simple stuff as like
making their yelp page good like what
were you doing
yeah so it's not that small we do have
some smbs like that but we actually
first started off in uh
mid market our clients would pay us like
a minimum of 10 grand a month
and what would you do for 10 000 a month
so nothing was cookie cutter it was all
custom it's like maybe they need seo
maybe they need to help on paid
management maybe they need some cro or
email marketing or a little bit of
everything right but the plans would
start at 120 a year right 10 a month and
scale up from there to
20 a month 30 a month whatever it may be
what was most in vogue as the service
when you started like the trend
everybody wanted and then what's the in
vogue thing today when we first started
it was mainly seo
and what does that mean though what does
that mean you use ha refs or something
and your employees like look which terms
they should rank for and then you write
an article for them
so it was optimizing their on-page code
helping build links creating content
promoting the content and making sure
that traffic converted into leads or
sales assuming if they weren't services
um and it was a positive roi for the guy
that sounds like a ton of work for 10
000 a month
it would start at 10. it depended on the
keywords how hard they were to rank for
and it would go up from there
and what about now sam i love when you
describe people's businesses because
you're just like uh so what does that
mean you just google their name and then
it doesn't show up and then you go write
an article with their name and it's like
what's the hustle dude you just read the
new york times and then you just cut out
half the words and then you hit send in
an email like is that what is that what
the hustle is
yeah
nailed it i mean it can be it like like
like you know uh
there's there's always more nuance and
complication in reality but like if you
can explain things in a fairly simple
way where it's like what's hubspot oh
they just make software so when you
people sign up for your website you can
email them and call them
you know what i mean like you could i'm
just trying to dumb it down a little bit
but when you look at the business when
they first started massive churn how to
add tons of features how to figure out
onboarding how to figure out training
there was a lot of stuff that went to
make hubspot a multi-billion dollar
company right a lot of people look at it
as email but they do more than email
they do more than a crm they've added
actually if anyone in the space has a 10
attraction they have a history of adding
a lot of those features for free which
is a smart model and then gobble up
market share get them into the ecosystem
and hopefully they stick around
and so what's what's the popular you
should do the ad reads uh for us yeah oh
that was amazing
by the way sam i think you should make
suburban dictionary which is just you
explaining businesses without like
any uh any of the complicated stuff like
yeah what is it well if you get covered
like this
call them and email them the the three
syllable dictionary like i i explain
complicated things but no word is above
three syllables that's what we're gonna
call exactly uh what by the way
i was just gonna say ben brought up one
point on that minority thing ben you
want to say that that sounds pretty
interesting you slacked us something but
neil kind of mentioned this too but like
this is really really
uh
in government work because the
government is like very hardcore about
hitting their quotas
for racial minorities and so around here
like i actually know a couple guys and
basically what they do
is
uh the people i know are all
african-american they get the contract
they put their name on the contract they
then outsource the entire thing to like
uh deloitte or kpmg or whatever and uh
they take like you know 15 of the
revenue or whatever they create a
consulting firm that's like the minority
minority inc and then minority inc goes
and gets the contracts and farms it out
to to like deloitte or whoever
that's great
i can't find this client info have you
heard of hubspot hubspot is a crm
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out-of-sync spreadsheets are
dueling databases hubspot grow better
[Music]
i lived in uh in indonesia for a while
and they had such a bad traffic problem
jakarta has like i think the worst
traffic in the world like you just going
two miles you might be there for two
hours
and uh so they were like okay we need to
create like a carpool incentive so how
do we create an incentive where if you
have three or more people in your car
then you can go in the fast lane and so
this so it worked for like you know a
month it was like oh wow this is great
if we carpool we get to go faster and
then this like little industry sprouted
up where people would just stand at the
edge of the carpool lane like a
hitchhiker and they'd be like oh get in
your car if you want a third rider i'll
just hop in and we could ride in the
fast lane and then they would get off on
the other side and ride back with
somebody else and so they would be
professional
like you know hov lane participants so
they would just spend all day riding
with you in your car so you'd be sitting
there and someone would just get in the
back seat with you it's just like a
random indonesian person and you would
give them 10 10 like rupees or whatever
and then 10 baht and then they would you
know get out on the other side a mile
later it was amazing
you uh
neil was was quick sprout uh ben there
you go uh was quick sprout i mean so
that was your main business quick sprout
and crazy egg were your main business
for a while
before it was just a blog and then
my co-founder he then ended up taking it
over now it's his blog
so what was your main source of of
revenue and income because
like i said i've listened to you forever
like you've been crushing it it seems
like for financially for like 10 plus
years
i don't know if i'm crushing it but uh
the main source of income was crazy for
most my life and then it ended up
becoming the ad agency
and sam you said something at the very
beginning that if i was listening to
this i'd be like wait
hold on i want to hear that story you
said something like just for kicks he
would like spin up a business that like
did 100k a month in revenue
what's an example of that tell that
story because that sounds awesome yeah
so everyone thinks like it's really hard
to make money online and then you got
these shysters or like buy this for a
thousand dollars and you become rich
which never really happens maybe every
once in a while but for most people it
doesn't so they create a business on
anything and people are like go create a
nutrition business my audience picked i
gave them like a lot of different
options they picked a nutrition business
and i was like all right let's create a
blog get a ranking get some traffic and
then funnel people in through quizzes
through uh emails and let's bundle them
into uh supplements rank higher on
amazon get traction and see what happens
and it did well
and that took you like
uh months years how long did it take it
wasn't months it was much more than that
i think it was a year right a little bit
less than a year i think it was like
nine or ten months
so it wasn't like one or two months
sadly but
a little bit less than a year so it's
pretty good it was an awesome it was an
awesome blog post series shawn you got
to google it google like quick sprout or
neil patel then like hundred thousand
dollars a month and it was like a
monthly update it was pretty amazing
i i don't think we may have deleted it
now i don't know if it's still a line
but and then so i took the money i made
from crazy egg and i would park it into
other things so it's like stock market
for a long time the stock market's had a
really crazy run right then you also
have things like investments a lot of
venture funds uh angel investments and
then sometimes you just get lucky
sometimes you don't and it's a numbers
game we had talked about doing a content
series like this to grow the podcast i
was like you know i think one of the
best ways to grow the podcast could be
if we
do a challenge like what you described
and one of the ideas was like what if
sam created his own uh
sam sticky stickyaki his own a condiment
brand and we basically show how we build
a dtc brand like from from idea to like
branding to marketing to and we just do
it all transparently to like
like get people hooked on okay let me
see how you guys actually build this
thing now it's a lot of works which is
why i think ultimately we didn't do it
but how well did that work for you was
that like just kind of like a good
content thing or was it like no that was
like
drove a lot of growth for the brand and
the blog i'm curious how well that
worked for you
it didn't drive as much growth for the
brand um but it did help out every
little bit like i did crazy experience
so i spent like a hundred and something
or two hundred and something thousand on
clothes
and
wanted to see what that did in business
meetings uh spent money applying first
class everywhere she wanted to see what
that would do but yeah i tried a lot of
different experiments and it was just
for
shits and giggles um and it was also a
reason to justify some of my expenses
and i'm like i want to apply first class
because i remember my first time flying
first class someone else paid for it i'm
like wow this is i've been missing out
this is a lot better than being crammed
up and flying all the way to europe from
los angeles you know in economy
and then i was like man let's do some
experiments and let's see if i can
justify this expense but yeah
that's amazing
and you just you did you say early on
that you just gave heaton so
did you invest in heat and shaw's other
company sean neera yeah
yeah so we're both neil we're both
investors in nira which is he he is your
cousin right
no brother-in-law brother-in-law yeah
sorry and uh heaton's amazing he's
another he's a great blogger as well and
sean and i both invested in his company
called nera which is either gonna
be a dud or it's gonna be like the
biggest company ever i know
like it's like a company that's close
like they're gonna close like
multi-million dollar contracts i would
guess that's it's like a big old
business potentially a big old business
but did you say that you gave him crazy
egg
uh so with crazy egg what ended up
happening is is what i wanted to do is
we were doing business forever together
and then eventually i just said hey you
can have the monthly distributions and
i'm gonna go create another business
why would you give that why
uh he didn't ask for it nor did he care
for it nor does he want it you know he's
never been about money neither him or i
have and we're not rich
i can't actually speak for him i'm not
rich i've just done well enough and i
don't spend as much so it's like don't
really need the money does that make
sense like if you just don't spend money
you don't really need
much cash dude you just said you dropped
200 000 on clothes what do you mean you
don't need money well that was
experiment right
but that's not my daily life like i'm
wearing a white t-shirt with stains that
my kids spits up on
um
they're probably like 10 20 bucks i
don't know what the white t-shirts cost
but they're not really white anymore so
i try not to do video recordings in
front of white walls anymore uh because
you can just tell the discoloration from
it nonetheless
so did sam say you live in brazil is
that what no i have a
uh division in brazil like we do
marketing in brazil for brazilian
companies and you live in texas where do
you where do you live
vegas vegas okay amazing and uh
so
have you um is it easy for you to keep
your burn rate down because like uh i i
was telling sam this i spend like i
don't know twenty five thousand dollars
a month now just like
and i'm not i don't even feel like i'm
dude i think sean you might i think you
might spend more than that now if i bet
you added up because i know how you
spend i bet you it's more than 25 it
might be it might be a little more uh
but it's not more than 30 i would say i
don't think it's more than 30. so i but
like it's yeah i got two little kids but
i got two kids but they're like babies
like like you know like
they don't eat food you know so so you
know there's diapers sure but like it's
not them it's meat
so
i would take 30.
you said it's a steep burn rate or it's
a
good burn rate i would take it i'll
trade with you okay gotcha so when you
say you don't spend much what do you say
is your monthly burner because i think
for most people listening right they
like most people don't talk about how
much they make or how much they spend
all right how much you make sometimes
that's sensitive how much you speak
well but but neil you actually wrote
this in a blog post you said uh you said
i spend this is i don't know if you're
actually i have no idea if you're single
or if you have a family and you can
avoid that
right now but you used to say in your
blog post that you go 15 000 a month is
all i need i'm happy that was like 10
years ago i think but uh that's but you
used to say 15 000.
single and no kids it was easy right now
if i had a guess on my burn rate 120 to
180 a month what that's insane so what
is how does that break down so what
what's the like what's the bulk of it
whether so house probably is the biggest
one
no i have no mortgage okay so you're
spending 120 180k without spending
anything on your home
uh property tax property tax
uh for both my homes and hoa dues is
probably close to 200 a year
okay great
so
[Music]
we've got 12 000 of the way there where
all right yeah
yeah
so there's
okay life insurance is 25 grand a month
what
my whole life policy yeah that's 25 to
300 a year
uh no no wait wait what what the hell is
a 25 000 a month life insurance policy
what can you explain that
this is just a
benefit like if i die my wife and kids
get money
like a life insurance policy
yeah well i get that but is that normal
i've never heard uh like either i'm done
but you're dumb who's dumb here
am i dumb because i've never heard of
anybody spending that much on their life
it's like an investment account it
builds over time
so it's not like it goes away right most
life insurance policies are for
call it 10 years and then you buy
another one mine just keep going and you
can borrow against it just think of it
as like a investment vehicle so that's
25 a month okay
now i understand
staff uh cleaners nannies driver we have
a full-time driver i think that ends up
being around 57 a month
um fifty seven hundred fifty seven
thousand
uh
you know a driver uber
what why are you
more affordable
i optimize for convenience in vegas
i go through this company they charge a
hefty premium i go through this company
and i have decals on my car so if i do a
meeting in front of a casino the car can
just stay in front of the casino it
doesn't have to move if i'm going to the
airport you can straight up pull up into
the plane or whatever you want to do and
you don't have to go through terminals
or anything like that so that makes it
like so part of your strategy as i'm
picking this up is that you
live the best lifestyle you want
and it's all expensible the way you do
it
uh i don't know if it's all expensive
isn't that what you meant with the decal
like it's a company it's like marketing
it's like a like a marketing vehicle for
you
so there's a limo company if i have
their own
windows i pay them
i can end up parking wherever i want in
theory not literally wherever i want but
in most cases i can park wherever i want
and the car can just sit there and wait
for me so all right so what else
anything else do you fly private he's
like i buy a daily disneyland fast pass
just in case i decide to go that day
um what's been what's been the number
one uh like kind of like where you feel
like most people don't most people think
this is too expensive and not worth it
but for me i get way more value i'll
give you an example in my life right so
i i thought i had burn rate until we
started talking so this is great i'm
feeling so much better about myself but
the one thing i did was i hired a
private chef so i was like all right
that i think i always thought that's the
lifestyle of the rich and famous and i
thought wow that's cool because you eat
healthy and it tastes great you don't
have to fuss with time and you know
cooking and dishes and groceries and all
that stuff
and so to me it's like a no-brainer i'm
like dude anybody with any kind of money
you should be like that should be one of
the first like fancy car later
private chef now like because i'm like
to me the value the reward way
outweighed the cost i think most people
don't typically make that trade sounds
like you've experimented with many ways
of spending money
what has been a good reward for
for cost uh trade that you're like
this one is is great that most people
don't do
i don't know i mean i'm in a bubble
because i have a lot of friends who are
like me sadly
in which we spend a lot and we don't
know it's reality i know that sounds bad
to say but it's true right uh
cook is not bad uh
housekeepers and best you don't have to
do your own dishes and stuff although
funny enough i enjoyed doing that and
ironing because it's uh it's kind of
like meditative for me it's relaxing i
don't know why watching tv and ironing
um
nanny's help so you get the freedom and
you can watch your kids when you want to
but you can also do meetings and stuff
like that
um the probably the the best expense i
ever
spend on is private planes
not because i like it it's uh i don't
mind playing commercial
not really any difference for me but it
helps me optimize for time so i can see
my kids more
because i have to sometimes do a lot of
meetings for work and just going and
then coming back the same day just
really in and out really quickly like
sometimes i'll be home quick enough like
go from vegas to utah for a conference
speak come back and i'll be home quick
enough to pick up my kid from school i
like to meet really well valuable that's
worth some money are you saving any
money then or are i mean are you just
taking a fat draw from the agency in
order to
pay for this or are you able to expense
a lot of it to the agency how does that
work i don't expense any of it to my
company
i just personally paid
so you're just the agency is just that
profitable of a business it's doing that
well
or investments or savings i've done well
enough in life or i'm okay why did you
do an agency so me and sam always talk
about like uh we have many mottos on
this podcast
um
for example we don't do public math
for example you don't say you're rich
you say you're post-economic uh these
are things we've picked up from from
guests along the way and one of the one
of the models one of the mottos that we
say
is uh you know
agencies suck and uh it's like
and the reason we say is not because
they uh like they do well that's not
that they suck it's like they suck as a
business choice like if i could i always
thought if i could choose between
software or an agency i'd do software
because it's like oh it's not a services
business it's gonna work while i sleep
and they can scale up and i don't have
to open up offices in poland and brazil
and all these other places
but you chose that you did software and
you chose agency now
um
why'd you make that choice and what's
great about agencies that i'm
kind of like not giving enough credit
for
so you're looking at business as in
software is more scalable it's more
desirable by public market ex hubspot
versus
accenture accenture has
way worse multiples than hubspot
accenture is a bigger company from a
revenue even a standpoint but now take a
different approach okay helps us
publicly traded companies you guys are
both hubspot employees i'm assuming
still is that correct
kinda sure whatever your guys's deal is
right but you guys are pretty much at
hubspot
now imagine creating a business and you
don't plan on going public you don't
care for the limelight you don't care
for any of that in business
what's a successful business
good revenue growth and good revenue and
profitability right
all that really matters at the end of
the day whether you grow or not grow is
how profitable are you would you guys
agree with that statement assuming
you're doing something that's ethical
and you're not selling drugs no
i wouldn't agree with that i would say
there's a third thing which is like is
this enjoyable and like do i like my
day-to-day and with the more people you
have
most people would say that's just a
little bit more headache uh than
than but that's not software or
consulting anytime you build a big
company you tend to have a large amount
of people whether it's hubspot or
whether it's accenture everyone has yeah
but you can have you can probably have a
much higher revenue per employee with
software versus let's say you own a
massive landscaping business you're
gonna have to have tens of thousands of
people
well but what's the difference from
dealing with how many people does
hubspot have like six thousand i don't
know five thousand six thousand is
probably a lot i'm guessing on the
number but what's the difference of
dealing with
five thousand or six thousand people and
twenty thousand people there's a point
where it doesn't matter and it's a lot
of people either way
like it's not like you're at fifty
people you still have thousands of
employees to deal with and you need
managers and layers and all that kind of
stuff yeah but you're hiring at some
good or bad you're hiring a different
type of person so for example if you're
vaynermedia they're based in new york
they can probably only afford to pay
some of their lower level employees 70
or 80 000 a year and so you just have to
get a ton of people like that and have
to have higher churn versus say a bigger
company where you're able to pay a
significantly higher salary because the
revenue per employee is much higher so
perhaps there's a slightly different
day-to-day with because of that not
necessarily let's say you're a
vaynermedia he could be doing it to
optimize for profit ones if i told you
his ltv was six seven eight years
right then at that point you can still
hire high quality people and pay my arm
and a leg
you got what i mean right like you look
at the extent
they're charging accounts so much money
and their contracts are long and i don't
know what vaynermedia's ltv is but
there's a lot of consulting companies
that have ltvs of six seven years for
clients
and their clients are spending you know
a hub spot yes just more revenue per you
can say potentially in software you can
get to more revenue per employee but i
know consulting companies that only take
on contracts that are like five six
million dollars and upwards
so you have high margins and you can
have a high revenue per employee but
either way no matter what as you build a
big business you're going to need more
people and it's a headache to manage
whether you pay them 70 000 or whether
you pay them 150 000 it's still more of
a headache and the notion that if you
hire someone for 150 000 i'm not saying
you're saying this it doesn't
necessarily mean they're a better
employee right and you know it just
means different types of headaches
correct exactly engineers for example
are very expensive in this economy right
so
the point i'm getting at is a consulting
company i had the demand for it a lot of
people want to pay me for marketing and
there was just so much demand it would
have been silly not to do and if i'm not
trying to go public or i'm not trying to
sell
money is money green is green as long as
you're happy doing what you're doing
take the cash will you ever sell the
company
i wouldn't say i would never sell the
company but i don't care to ever sell
the company because i love what i'm
doing
we also have good growth too right like
i don't know what will grow this year
60 something percent which isn't bad
you know with the market going up and
down and fluctuating 60 something
percent is my guess at our size is
decent yeah the part i was actually
talking about was a little bit more like
i think you're you're totally right that
like if you're gonna win big you're
gonna end up with a bunch of employees
and like you know it might look like 150
might look like a thousand it might look
like 10 000 but like you know in either
case you're gonna have managerial work
and headaches and it's just different
types
the part i was really talking about was
like you know i've now built let's say a
media company content and then it's like
um
done educational stuff so courses which
are like you know a different thing and
then there's like a built software
company and you know we ended up selling
that one and then it's like and then
there's um
services which is like client services
like like consulting or agency model
and what i hate what i what i love about
content media is it's actually pretty
fun to create and it's cool because a
lot of people consume it so they kind of
you know you get that like hit um
but you got to like you got to bake the
cake every day right so like you know
the hustle or like the milk road or this
podcast like we have to come on and
create the content again uh you know for
the most part we we're not doing like
super long evergreen stuff uh so you
know like with the hustles the daily
news that our milk roads and daily
newsletters we got to bake that cake
every day whereas software it was like
we built one product and yes we might
we will improve it over the course of a
year you know
every year we're going to improve it
but like fundamentally um
we didn't have to like recreate the
product come up with a new viral story
or a new great content segment uh that
would like require like a new genius uh
with software it's like you come up with
one genius moment and then you sort of
refine it make it work better over time
and get rid of bugs and things like that
so i prefer that part of software which
was like making a product rather than
making kind of like a disposable
uh you know consumable piece of content
or like i have an e-commerce company and
like it's a pain in the ass to have
supply physical products that are supply
chain
constrained and like we have a warehouse
we got warehouse problems with our
e-commerce business and so i'm like man
digital was sweet compared to e-commerce
but e-commerce is quite profitable that
kicks off a bunch of profits that's nice
so every business has these pros and
cons and i always thought agency was
like
um the part i always thought was a pain
in the ass was like the client services
you are reinventing the next campaign
and the next winning marketing you know
formula for them
and you have to keep clients happy all
the time and clients are sort of like
never satisfied in a way that like
they if software is like you can have
nameless faceless customers that like
yeah some percentage of them will will
write into your help desk that's in the
philippines or whatever but like you're
not having to like
you know send account reports to your
you know your big client to keep them
happy yeah but you everyone has their
own problems in software a lot of people
have turned this issue and they can't
figure it out or they have competitors
who come into the marketplace and just
undercut them on pricing for the same
features because it's cheaper and
cheaper to build software these days
right so they all have their own problem
to me i look at it as if you can find
the right people so every time i start a
company i find in people to put in place
that have already done it multiple times
before because your risk of failure are
lower and they already know everything
to do so i don't have to deal with
client relationships i don't have to
deal with customer service or anything
like that i get to do what i enjoy doing
which is go and create content be the
face etc and uh my wife enjoys what she
gets to do right she gets to donate the
money although we don't really consider
us donations we look at as investing
we're investing in people although we
really don't ever collect any money back
it's more so you're investing into
making the world a better place or
people's lives a better place or
whatever it may be
what's uh
who were
who were your first three clients
at this at this agent because
i don't know they were small companies
and right now who's an example client
like
a fortune 100 software company
like that is a typical company think of
any big large corporation in b2b that's
a great example of one of our customers
or even b2c actually think of any
fortune 500 company that's a prime
example of a customer what's uh and
who's the ceo of your agency are you
no i'm never the ceo i'm a terrible
manager i'm one of the worst managers
ever uh his name is mike gullickson he
was the ceo no he was the president of i
prospect which is an ad agency owned by
uh densu i believe in
i prospect maybe they had four or five
thousand people is my guess
and what when you how early into the
business did you have a hired ceo or
hired leader
day one i won't start a business without
a ceo from day one and what did you pay
them in the first year
first year is my co-founder
for like 100
and that's because you basically went
and drummed up 100 grand worth of
business and you're like hey mike uh i
got i got this clients to give a hundred
grand you want to run this thing for me
and help it get deployed
no uh our business didn't start off that
way i probably put a total of five
million bucks into the business of my
own money so it's bootstrap but not
really bootstrapped if that makes sense
it's kind of cheating um and it gets
easier and easier as your entrepreneur
right the more the more successes you
have and i'm not saying i'm successful
by any means the more capital you have
to deploy into the next thing so reduces
chances of
failure and when it's your own money
this is just my
thesis and i could be wrong on this i
have no data points when it's your own
money you're much more careful than when
if you raise like 15 20 30 million
dollars of venture capital right you
really look at every single dollar
uh but mike was the ceo from day one
he's a great operator has no agency
experience eventually we got in a
president and then eventually from there
we got in a ceo
and have you guys crossed a hundred
million in revenue yet
yeah we do nine figures that's crazy man
so
what i mean that's just pretty wild that
you're able to like parlay this blog
that was already always kind of a
juggernaut but this blog into a
nine figure a year business i mean
that's amazing
yeah
it's been a
good run i hope it
i'm knocking on wood although you
probably can't hear for the chris but uh
i hope it keeps going and more so we're
just having fun like for me what i enjoy
doing is building a business um i know i
have an expensive lifestyle i generally
don't do stuff with the money like i
overpay like house staff like nannies
and stuff like that when i say overpay i
drastically overpay not by like 10 20 30
40 like i really mean drastically
overpay because i look at people i'm
like if you're cleaning a house how are
you gonna live on this like i'll give
someone six figures to do that i know
that sounds kind of crazy or stupid but
like i'm not giving my kids money so
might as well take care of other people
in this world who need it more than um
but we do did you say that you're not
giving kids money
yeah i'm not gonna give my kids money
nothing leave nothing
we have a trust set up what they'll get
maximum is like if they're on the street
and they can't provide and they're going
to be suffering like i will help pay
their bills
um or put them in a normal home or like
if my kids like i want to be a doctor
and i want to go spend all my time in
africa helping other people out and i
won't get paid for this and i need you
know
x five thousand dollars a month to live
or ten thousand so i can just go
volunteer all my time but like sounds
good i'll pay for that but like i won't
give them money for the sake of it like
if they're like i want to go travel to
see italy or i want a
honda accord and like go buy your own
honda accord go travel on your own with
your own dime like
you know i don't believe in just giving
people money because i think there's
other people who need it more than we
do sean are you gonna give your kids
money
i don't really thought about it like my
oldest is two so i think i got some time
to figure that out but
i
i lean more towards so i've kind of
heard both arguments like um i know
somebody who they if some people are
like you know uh you know i do there's
some people i i'm definitely not in the
camp of i do this for my kids i want to
leave my kids with a whole bunch cause
i'm like that may be the worst thing you
could do for them um not because it
means that they're ruining
drug addicts yeah you take away you know
agency in a way right like you you want
people to
um
like it's not that it's good or bad it's
actually just it's just way lower on the
totem pole of priorities it's like i
just don't even focus on that it's like
if i'm gonna leave them something it's
gonna be a certain set of character
character traits and skills and like uh
mentality that's what i'm trying to
leave money is like i don't know 15th on
the list of like i don't know we haven't
even gotten to think about that yet but
i've thought a lot about what are the
character traits and mentality and like
mindset and skills that i think i can
help build and like that's the focus
that's the one that matters that's the
that's the gift if whatever else comes
from beyond that i don't know we can
figure out like the foot it's like the
footnotes
so like
we're very similar
i have a two-year-old and a less than
one-year-old right
and i look at it as you want them to be
productive units of society right you
want them to be ambitious hungry uh
caring thoughtful happy like whatever it
is there's a lot of characteristics that
you may want children to be but i look
at it as like they don't need money even
like with my wife and i we go over our
expenses
and
we look at what we spend on travel
and we do some of this because it's
easier but like my wife and i are
actually considering cutting out all
private and just going commercial now
the main reason our expenses are high is
due to cobit so if it wasn't for cobit i
would just be going in a normal airport
i didn't know how covered was going to
impact with young kids could afford it i
was like yes just start flying private
and we haven't gone back to commercial
yet but we're thinking about going back
because like my wife and i look at the
money is like yeah we spend all this
money on travel and airfare and hotels
if we donated the money people would
have a better life do we really need it
that much what do you do when you donate
that like what's a good way to donate in
your opinion so there's like
you know ranging from not donating to
donating to one thing to donate to a
bunch of things to like getting involved
or seeing the impact or like you know i
know people who if they donate to africa
they'll actually their family will go
take a trip every year so that they're
more connected to the people and they
actually see the impact and they take
their kids with them so they see the
impact like
what have you found that's a good way to
give
so we have a balance it's my wife and i
team up um this is gonna sound bad but i
don't like volunteering my time my wife
loves volunteering her time i think it's
very inefficient for me to volunteer my
time i should make the money
versus volunteering my time because the
money for the hours spent if we donated
the money would have a much bigger
impact to the cause than if i actually
spent my time i don't my wife
yeah and my wife loves spending the time
and like from going to soup kitchens or
whatever it may be
so she picks the causes we have a few
thesis so like one thesis is is we or
not really thesis but rules one rule is
is we don't like money going to
organizations that have tons of high
overhead we actually want our money
going to the causes so if it doesn't go
to the cause then we tend to not pick
that um organization the second thing
that we look for is
uh organizations who are
like uh self-sufficient right it's just
like how can this continue going even if
someone wasn't managing so like a great
program for example
is my wife likes donating to women's
education we used to donate also to
men's education as well so you find
these people in these villages you say
hey you can't afford to go to school get
a degree we'll pay for you to go to
college go get a degree come back teach
kids in your village for a few years
whether it's under a tree or anything
people can learn anywhere right and then
you know go move on with your life and
do whatever you want but at least you're
giving back to your own community and
what we found is when we started giving
because we've been doing this for so
long now uh well actually not that long
but when i mean long i'm talking about
like 10 11 years where we've been
donating and it's picked up quite a bit
over the last like five six years
when we started giving the money to men
a lot of the men we saw a very low
conversion rate from them actually
coming back and teaching people in the
village well when we gave the money to
women for their education a lot of them
came back and
fulfilled on the promise it's not like
you get a signed contract right it's
just like hey we're gonna pay for
everything come back help people out
within your village which country
we've done this in both india and africa
so different parts of africa and uh in
india and then another program that
we've done is like growing gardens where
a lot of people who have aids don't take
the right uh don't take their medication
and aren't doing well they're getting
they're given the medication for free
but if your body doesn't have the right
nutrients it rejects it so what we'll do
is we'll do programs like growing
gardens we'll give them money they grow
food and then not only do they
eat nutritiously or well they'll more
likely take their medication and you're
also growing enough food so that way
other people in the village can also
eat
so it's like but my wife picks all the
causes she vets them she loves it like
she'll go this is wednesday in two days
she'll end up going to a function uh
scouting out more non-profits and
organizations i won't go
like i think it's a waste of time i'm
like if i'm gonna make more money she
can donate it it's a better roi than if
i go spend three four hours mingling
when she could just do that and i can go
make more so that way we can donate more
other than your own private businesses
what have been your best financial
investments that's allowed you to to
donate and and make a lot to give away
stock market has done really well
companies like apple amazon google
facebook i know facebook's down but they
still have been a tear if you just
bought the stocks early enough um
because some of these companies have
grown 30 40 a year in the public markets
compounding right and it really adds up
uh angel investments have done really
well for me and
i would say probably those are the two
biggest
um stock markets still has done well
although in the last 6 months i've taken
a beating because i'm in 100 tech
companies like i don't diversify like
everyone's like oh you need some oil and
you need this i'm like yeah i'm just
gonna go all tech and people are like oh
you're silly look how much you lost but
if you look at the whole time when i
first got in i've done well and i invest
in what i understand and i'm 37 so who
cares you know another 10 years
everything should rebound assuming you
pick the right companies what's your
portfolio look like in terms of
percentages
not including private businesses
my public portfolio i if i had a guest i
probably don't even have more than 20
stocks
amazon i i won't be able to name them
all but
amazon google facebook apple microsoft
hubspot salesforce adobe
atlassian shopify
um i'm missing some as well
and of your liquid of your of your
liquid net worth how much is in public
equities versus other
versus real estate
just non-agency if if i think at your
agency is your agency the only company
that you own a significant stake in if
yes exclude that then what's your
portfolio look like
uh no i have quite a bit of other
companies because i started using a lot
of the cash to buy other companies for
like three four or five x ebitda and
then you just fix them and grow them and
then just cash flow
um
i would so if i look just at cash
invested in other companies that aren't
mine like not companies i'm buying that
or anything like that
i would probably say 80 to 90 percent is
in stocks
what companies were you buying
uh
any that we can find that we like like
we bought uber says it was a software
company bought it for 120 put 3 million
into it
um it took i think less than
seven or eight months to get to a
million a month in revenue
what's it called
ubersuggest hrs competitor that one did
well uh we just bought another map
a lady named lisa
crazy
and then we just bought another one we
haven't announced it we bought it for
8.6 i think a month ago a month and a
half ago
uh so we'll see it does a hundred
thousand a month uh we think we can grow
it within
12 months to probably like
four or five hundred grand a month in
profit so forget revenue we just will
look at it as a cash flow so do you uh
have rules around that like okay i have
to be able to grow it using
neilpatel.com or it has to be in the
marketing niche so the agency benefits
no it's like
would you buy like brick you know like a
[__] laundromat or
if i can grow it i won't do too much
brick and mortar but i've invested in
other people's brick and mortar like i
have a friend who does a lot of brick
and mortar businesses um
like one of my buddies has a roofing
company and i was like oh cool you can
buy it for 3x it's good size and i can
show you a few things and we can
probably increase the profit by like 60
within 12 months so it's like it's just
good cash flow right like if you're
getting like 30 40 50 returns on your
money
it's great and then you also have to
keep in mind because of
my
my history and i've been doing this long
enough i also can get debt at really
cheap terms and large amounts of debt
like i can get debt at like 3.6 plus
silver so if i'm buying a business for
5x in many cases because of
the economics of my whole portfolio
you know some businesses i put down like
on the one that was um 8.6 2.6 was uh
paid over
12 or 18 months or something like that
but we put six mil up front i could have
got a loan for it but i was like yeah
this is easier to put the six mill and
not deal with the paperwork but
sometimes we'll just do loans on 100 of
it but zero down right
and what do you like okay so you do what
you do now so you have your time and
it's pretty much probably fully
allocated let's say to the agency and
then some of these other things um
if somebody was smart
but didn't have your you have a bunch of
visibility you kind of know where your
industry is going you see adjacent
opportunities but hey i'm not going to
go do them i don't have the time
uh what are opportunities that you see
that you think
somebody listening to this
who's just like smart hustler
like
i got more time than i have ideas um i
got more time than i have money where
would you go if you were that person
what would you what would you suggest
for them to look at as like you know
opportunities that you see today
i would look for opportunities in
anything that they're good at and i know
that's not the answer that you're
looking for but what i found that the
issue is when people go look for
opportunities that make some money when
you're not passionate you don't put in
the time and energy required to actually
make it successful that's a big issue we
see maybe some people have it in them
where they can make something successful
because they'll just tough it out but
most people we see will just quit
because they just hate what they're
doing
and so but i think a lot of people don't
know what they love to do they don't
have like they don't if they already had
what they love to do they wouldn't be
you know looking for opportunities so
you know uh sort of like a by-definition
problem there right so somebody who's
who's thinking about okay i don't love
what i'm currently doing i'd like to i
want to get to where this guy's at but
which is basically like seems happy and
successful right um he he seems like he
said he loves what he's doing i'd love
to do that but what if i don't know
right it's like when my sister was going
to college my dad asked her you know
she's like what should i major in he's
like i don't know what's her favorite
subject and she was like lunch like you
know i don't i don't have a favorite
subject i don't love any of these
subjects um so what am i supposed to do
like am i just out uh you know i'm just
not one of those you just having a lot
of different
until you find what you're passionate
about because if you try a lot of
different things you'll typically find
something that you're naturally good at
usually what you're naturally good at
you'll also tend to favor and what you
like and then just double down on that
but if you're looking for industries
with opportunities i see a huge slowdown
in e-commerce not only the e-commerce
market shrinking i'm not saying that but
the growth in the e-commerce market
isn't as what it was once used to be
right when coveted first kicked off so
you're gonna see the multiples go down
to buy e-commerce shops d2c brands right
so great opportunity for buying and go
fix them up and grow them and scale them
another great opportunity right now is
uh free so i look at the whole software
market as really backwards
okay
in which
right now it doesn't matter if you're a
hubspot or canva eventually someone can
just create a me too company and just
undercut you on pricing and what i've
learned is if you can create a software
company that already has a brand that
has a free product and you just make it
really good for free and you just keep
adding more and more to it
a great example of this is photo p so
there's this company called photo p it's
uh
uh we love it photoshop and it's like
they make very little to no money so i
hit up one of my buddies who
is great at outreaching and i told him i
want photo fee i offered him 10 million
he said no offered him 20 million he
said no
i can take photo p make it a really good
canva competitor undercut him on pricing
whatever be worth 10 20 40 billion
whatever they are no but i probably can
cashflow that thing to like or five
million a month in ebitda
right it's like who cares what it sells
for what it's worth
you're saying make it free and you're
saying cash flows like a [__] so
what how do you take a free product in
cash like how would you explain that
well he said he said a canva a canva
knockoff
canva knockoff so you make you make
almost 99 of it for free you charge for
one percent but that one percent is
enough where you can drive in the
revenue so you don't ever make as much
as like a canva or like a mailchimp or a
hubspot but hey if you can make millions
a month in profit it's still good what's
your math there so when what's the
calculus when you're thinking so like
let's say photo p
according to similar web has 10 million
uniques a month or something what was
your math
is that right
yeah it is right uh
we researched it
yeah so like what was your calculus to
get to uh four million and even a month
like what would how many people would
you need to run it and what was the
what's the calculus there
sure so
i can probably get the thing from 10
million visitors i can so let's say i
bought it for 20 right he wouldn't sell
to me for 20. um i've never outreached
him but i had a buddy outreach to him
for me who just does all my outreach so
let's say i bought it for 20 i'd put
another 10 into it so now i'm out 30
million dollars
i'm really good at growing traffic and i
know i can grow this thing to roughly 40
million uniques a month i just have a
i don't know how but for some weird
reason i know traffic really well and
how to calculate what i can get it to
and all this kind of stuff right and
i've done enough research and
competitors of what features drive x
amount of traffic
just looking at so many competitors in
the space so let's say if i get it to 40
um what is it called 40 million and what
what are the one or two things that
you'd get at the 40 million like seo
basically
so uh more seo more virality uh
increasing the quality of the templates
increasing features uh adding ai in
there like click a button we can
automatically detect backgrounds remove
it filters for social media because a
lot of people use them for social media
logo generator website as a lead gen
[__] like that
right so then so let's say you got up to
40 million right
at 40 million i can easily monetize
let's call it like
one percent of the traffic or let's be
even more conservative like a half a
percent 200 000 people
if i have 200 000 people hypothetically
paying three dollars a month okay
that's 600 000 the reason i give you on
average three dollars in certain
countries you may want to charge
different pricing like india and stuff
like that so it's more affordable so
three dollars a month and at three
dollars a month if a customer stays for
ten months that's six million dollars
you can probably run the thing with less
than a million million and a half and
burn each month
so then you think oh so then for a
million and a half burn you would need
once you have tons of revenue right when
you don't have tons of revenue your burn
is much lower on the monthly basis yeah
but so then how many people then if it's
you're looking at 30 people you need to
run that operation
i i don't even think 30 but let's say 30
total so i think i can actually run the
thing for under a million dollars a
month
right so i'm just trying to do the math
in my head but i mean the revenue was
under a million two there
was like 600 000 or something right
600 000 a month but if a customer stays
for 10 months you're looking at 6
million dollars
[Music]
no no
okay if they're paying three dollars a
month if you have 4 40 million not 4
million but 40 million you're converting
a half a percent that's 200 000 paying
customers a month if they pay you three
dollars a month that's 600 000 they last
for 10 months that's 6 million dollars a
month in mrr over a year you're making
72 million dollars in revenue
that's crazy
you're a very interesting person you uh
i just i think i dig you because you've
got your hands at so many different
things
i honestly don't at this point i don't
run anything i come up with ideas i have
really good operators who are great at
execution like go do this it'll make
money here's a play with go and just do
it so how many businesses do you own
i don't know i don't really count i only
look at over under 10
over
over under 20.
i don't know 20 is probably getting
close
so probably under if i had a guess
and how many of those 20 how many of
those 20 companies have more than five
employees full-time employees
i don't know i don't really count
employee head count i only know my ad
agency head count because they do
reports and i get in my board meeting
decks like i'm like oh we got 700 people
and you own 100 of most of these
companies it seems like you're not
raising extra capital you might you give
your ceo of really anything
um i always give equity to
uh profit share i usually have a partner
who runs things will get equity and then
i'll do profit share what's the uh ideal
setup for profit sharing and equity for
your partner
uh partner give them maybe 10 of the
business they run it plus a really nice
salary when i mean nice salary industry
or more than industry
and then you have a pool for employees
like another 10 pool so then you losing
total 20 i'm left with 80 myself i put
up all the money if it does well great
if it doesn't i lose the money no one
else is on the line uh if it does well
no one has to pay me back the money
everyone just takes their distributions
the moment it turns profitable from a
monthly standpoint does that make sense
they don't actually have to pay back any
of the other stuff and then do you also
do give them 10 the distribution or do
you make that even uh heavier
for them
well if i'm losing 20 in total which is
my deal structure then 20 of the profits
gets distributed on a monthly basis
that's crazy
i love hearing about this what do you
think sean yeah i think it's dope i um i
had just seen you kind of from afar for
a while that i i got i know he you know
loosely like we're friends but uh
so you know i didn't know a lot of the
story i know i knew sam has talked about
you before on the plot i think it's or
maybe off the pot i'm not sure but sam
had told me some cool stuff um but i
didn't know a lot of this so for me this
was dope because i got to learn a bunch
of new things uh sometimes when we have
a guest it's like dude i've already
listened to 10 of your things i've been
following you for five years you know so
it's like i already know a lot of it and
i'm doing sort of like
translation work for the audience i'm
like tell them about this hey tell them
about that thing you did uh versus in
this like i genuinely wanted to know a
bunch of the stuff and i thought you
know uh
this is interesting to me yeah you're
great there's two people that i wanted
to talk to sean who are like neil so i
mean there's neil so i wanted neil i
like finding these people that like are
doing really well and a lot of people
know about but there's also this whole
other world of people who have no idea
who they are neil you're one of those
folks i've been i'm an og reader so i've
known you forever the other one is syed
so syed we talked about syed a bunch on
here him and neil i think are very
similar which is very generous but also
like pretty cutthroat when it comes to
business and has their hands in just
dozens of different things and they're
just quietly crushing it and not even
talking about it and he's a very
generous person too i know he has a
school i think in the same city i have a
school in or a different city i don't
know he actually went to go see his
school but uh really generous guy uh him
and i have built schools in
third world countries and stuff like
that yeah it's just like you you too
you guys are i don't know if you're like
this neil but i know it seems like he's
like this where he like
has this uh you know software business
that's making who knows tens of many
tens of millions uh in revenue and
probably that much in profit but and he
like buys a gas station or like he like
just it's just like dude are you kidding
me like you're a you're like a tech
tycoon and you also own like 30 gas
stations it's just kind of funny here's
the thing some of those businesses sell
for like 3x ebitda you get 33 returns on
your money if you have good operators
and you can put technology in place in
marketing and you can grow to maybe 50
times irr that's great it's just the
question of can you scale it up and can
you do ones that are large enough i know
i'm just saying it's cool that you know
this stuff that's what you're eclectic
yeah
him and i actually shouldn't speak for
him but i'm a little off right but the
the madness or the methodology i think
is great for cash flow it's terrible if
you want to be like oh i'm going to
create the next airbnb and take this
thing public and be like on the farms
list like it's not what i do
is that are you motivated to become a
billionaire what what's your motivation
factor what are you motivated by
well i won't ever be a billion i'm not
saying i have the opportunity to but
even if i did uh i would never be there
because we donate our money and when i
mean donate like not wait till you're
dead to donate like actually donate on
an annual basis
how do you figure out how do you figure
out how much you want to give
because there's always like like when i
think about it i think like well i could
also invest this money it's going to
grow i'm gonna give more later but then
i'm not helping somebody now
and so what's the right number what's
the right percentage basically for me to
be giving on an annual basis how do you
figure that out for yourself
whatever my wife wants to give
what person what percentage does that
come out to
uh we don't have a percentage keep in
mind businesses are so large i can get
loans for anything on almost any type of
business i can't go buy a business for a
million dollar a billion dollars but if
i wanted to buy a business for 100
million dollars i can go get a loan on
that like literally for most of it
so i still i don't have to worry anymore
about do i need more of it to invest
it's just we find the right causes and
is it going to make a big enough impact
that's more that's more about how we
look about donations we don't really
look at it from the aspect of am i
donating x dollars or too high of a
percentage we look at it as do we
actually think it's going to make a big
impact in the next year or short run or
two years we don't want to wait like 10
20 years to see an impact we also don't
want to put money towards like things
like
cancer research i think cancer is really
important i know a lot of people who
have died from cancer but i don't have
enough money to make it
into cancer versus you know solving some
of the basic things out there like i can
make an impact on things like education
in a region i can't make an impact on
cancer i just don't have enough cash for
that
where uh what is your school you said i
have a school that sounds tight i want a
school
uh i've never seen it we have a school i
think it's in cambodia and we've done a
few others but i don't really keep track
my wife does and
you know the bigger thing is it's not my
school it's more so the kids school and
are they learning and
getting value from it i uh i remember
the first school that i bought and
forgot about i was gonna say um
when i buy my school it's for sure gonna
be my school they might attend
my school in cambodia yeah
i'm like that guy i bought a couple i've
got a couple schools in this couch
cushion back here just i just forgot
about it i just it's a little scene i
played in a while ago i remember when i
was on college camps i saw like you know
whoever the rothschilds or like the
rockefeller's uh name plate or whatever
on the like uh
the library at duke campus and i was
like who would do this what's the point
of this you know like so it's already
nice not that kind of schools i don't
have that kind of money mine's like
little kids i didn't understand the
appeal until you said you basically
described a school you have and forgot
and have never visited and i was like ah
that sounds like something i want i
don't want my name played on you know
the villanova like 10th library on
campus but like
just to know that there's you know
12 kids in vietnam attending my school
they're wondering why does this name
have so many a's and it's you know who
is this who is this benefactor silent
benefactor who has forgotten where our
school where school is that sounds like
a perfect blend of giving and egomania
that i live for so that's perfect
neil we uh we usually so we don't have
guests on often and when we do we
typically never just ask them questions
like this we like it's more of a
conversation where we're brainstorming
stuff we asked you tons of questions
because you're just a very fascinating
person i hope you'll come on soon and
you can actually brainstorm uh like
another uber suggests or something like
that you know like actually go through
some of this i i hope you'll come back
again because this is awesome yeah it
was so funny i was doing the interview
i'm like oh crap i should have never
told people how much i spent a month
should i never told people i donate
money and i was just like
it goes against a lot of what my wife
and i do we're more of don't tell anyone
anything live our lives and
do whatever it makes
you only told it because it's not like
you're bragging we like kind of begged
you to tell like we were
kind of got under we were like yeah tell
us go go tell us it's not like you're
like i don't think that's bragging
it's not even bragging it just feels
weird to talk about expenses right
because there's so many people who
struggle for like clean water or shoes
right because i was like yeah
yeah yeah but this is interesting those
people uh if they ever listen to this
podcast they've already been filtered
out by our douchiness in other uh
episodes so don't worry those anybody
who's sensitive to that's probably gone
by now but also there's there's actually
a lot of like i actually pretty
passionately believe this like not only
am i curious from like a
oh i wanna know i wanna learn uh but
like i actually pretty strongly believe
that the way that people are like treat
money as a pretty taboo thing
um actually is like a net like
a huge net negative on most people so
like
you know people don't know what other
people make therefore they don't know
what like they don't know when they're
underpaid they don't know what's
possible they don't ever like sometimes
the most valuable conversations i have
with somebody is just somebody for whom
they do something like something's very
normal to them it would be abnormal to
me but it has now expanded my world view
of what's possible and what could be
normal for me like oh maybe it could be
normal to actually like give more donate
more have a school actually that sounds
like something i actually would go talk
to my wife about today is like something
we should go do
that like it's not because you weren't
bragging about it you highly you just
kind of
were honest about how you live your life
which is no there's nothing wrong with
that that's great in my opinion and it
expands other people's worldview for
something maybe they want to go do or
something that they haven't considered
and like it's really weird to me that we
keep the stuff under wraps and if
somebody's just honest
about like the way they live their life
it's sort of like there's like all this
like negative taboo around it and like
[__] that i don't like that at all and
um
it's been like when sam first met me i
think i think i've told the story before
but like the second day i met him and
then like the next day he messaged me on
facebook investor was like
so like how much do you make and he was
like no like what do you pay yourself
he's like so then what he and then i
like i was like whoa that's like super
forward and he's like but he told me why
he was like so i'm trying to figure out
how much to pay myself as an
entrepreneur i have no [__] clue and
like my investors think i should make
this much but i don't know is that
normal and like i can kind of ask you
and dance around it or like i'm just
asking like five friends what they make
in the same role as i am it's like
startup ceo and like that'll help you
figure out what's normal what's the
range of like possibilities here and
then after that he was like
so what do you do with the money like
what do you invest he's like wow that's
a lot you know what are you investing
that i was like yeah he's like what are
you investing in i'll start telling him
and he's like cool i'm investing in this
and now i got new ideas about what i
could be investing and i it really
became very obvious to me in that moment
i was like
oh [__] you're at a massive advantage if
you have a few people you trust that you
can talk openly about this sort of thing
with and the podcast was basically
taking that doing it at scale i was like
all right well what if me and sam are
pretty honest about like the [__] we do
and like what if we could get guests to
be honest about the [__] they do they're
like that's actually a pretty valuable
resource for people who don't have five
they don't happen to have that lucky
group of five friends who are all
motivated entrepreneurs who are also
open and honest about what they do it's
like well not everybody's located in a
place where they have five people
geographically around them that they can
trust to talk about that stuff and so
the pod kind of like serves as that so
that's my uh justification for why you
shouldn't feel bad about about sharing
that information
did it work neil do you do not feel but
if you want we'll bleep it out or
whatever if you feel like that too okay
it is what it is i still feel bad but it
is what it is
i thought it was yes
i thought it was a great speech show and
i i i felt good about that thank you
deal
that was a great speech but i i i still
feel bad because i look at money as like
a tool to help other people and i'm not
saying that's right or wrong that's how
i just do but i also know i spend more
than i should um and i probably should
cut back and
live a more humble life and spend a lot
less yeah dude i'm inspired by how you
spend and how you live and it's uh you
know you've done some good in the world
by inspiring me
[Music]
you